.
O
ROD ARCUT
ERDOGLIMRCH AN
BAEDSEVE
SITIONTIHE IS AMONG THOSE WHO SA
THE T IS RESNSR THE  RESPONS BUF
FI
LET', CNN
T'S NOT A WIT FO
AIS  ATIIS --
E LIKELY TO  TO
PORE
I MEAOU KNOW, I, TO OKNUMBERS.R
ALL THE POLLINE FOECTIONS.
DID HMAL
KILILUHE LEADER OF THE
THAT SLIGHITNTDENT ERDOGAN
D YODENG VERNFING
HIS SECOND ROUNDT A
WPOSSIBLE.OITMEERNAGSITELECRAST
NOW, YVEO WARUNNIN
VOTES.E IMINATIALLY EMERGEASK
USE ONLY THE TOP TWO WILL
BE HEADEWAF.
ELECTIONAPPENS TO THAT?
NATION ONALISTS WHO
DN'T VOTE FOPRERGAS ALLIEN
GOT E T
A GABECKY AN
WLDRRIS DRTY,
KINGMAKER.
TATUS.
RTIEANT NO--
>> WE ARTO HAVE
HE IININ D
HIS SMALL ALLIANCE TO SEETHER TE
SE ANYONE.
HE
VOTED FOR HIMWI T WHATEVER
TAKING.OUENTL THISO OP, YOU  NT
THE ROLE O
LET'S TALK ABOION,
TY WILL LMOCAN  SINOFG TO DO FY
QUESTHO BE TCHALLENGE.
AL DISAPPOINTMENAMONGST THHEOPP.
NC INPECRYTH
THIS UNITED FR THIBEFORE.
COALO UNSEAT THEIR
PRISTHEYISOF MUCTHE POPULATION
PROMISING THATY
UNDEPAOPPOSITIONDO WIN.
HAT
EY TS.THEY
THIS FROM
E TH COMING OUD PUTTINKEMAL KIL.
D NOW YOU HAVE THIDISAPPOINTME
RETHE SECOND ROU
DAY,AYING TODAHE'S NOT GOING ANR
INERE YOU HADHA, YESTERDAY WE
HIGH TURNOUT ELEIONS.ES HAVE
YEST TURNOUT,
SHAIRS.SUTWE THE
TO
SPE WANTED CHANGE ELECTION
ARESULTS, YOUEY.
OF POLARIZN IN
OU, VEENT MEN.
THE CORKD
T RKER